hello everyone and welcome to Magnus
Carlson's last moments as World
classical Champion uh these are the last
games that he will play as World
classical Champion he will face three
opponents here in the Norwegian chess
League uh first opponent is Levy Andre
talakson uh second one will be John will
be Kammer and the third and final
opponent will be David Howell uh who he
will play tomorrow uh so uh let's check
it out it's quite a fun game and in case
some of you uh still don't know Magnus
will not be defending his title as World
classical champion on the 7th of April
uh Yani polishi and the dingler and will
start their World Chess Championship
match and the winner of that match will
uh take the the title of world classical
Champion so that being said uh let's see
how it went it's a very nice uh
classical uh debate we have E4 E5 Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5
Magnus goes for the uh URI Lopez we have
Ponte A6 morphy's defense and now Bishop
to A4 with Knight to F6 castles Bishop
to E7 and now Pawn to D3 we have B5 so
all the standard stuff Bishop B3 castles
and now challenging the pawn with Pawn
to A4
uh uh going for that B5 Pawn so here we
have Bishop to B7 Now The Rook is nicely
defended and Knight beat to D2 uh we
have Pawn to D6 and pawn to C3 Knight to
A5 now going after the bishop Bishop the
C2 and pawn to C5 so nothing new here
we've seen this uh uh a hundreds of
times Rook D1 we have Rook to E8 Knights
the F1 and now Queen to C7 we have
Knight to G3 and the bishopter f8 with
Bishop to G5 by Magnus and here Knight
to D7 and this position has been reached
before a captures uh on B5 is a known
movie here in this position D4 is a
known movie moving the bishop back is a
known move uh Knight the F5 is a known
move but here Magnus plays Ponte H4 and
it is now as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game what's the idea of
Ponte H4 probably Magnus says he's
playing a lower rated opponent you can
see that there's quite a bit of a
difference in raiding 2852 versus 23 41.
uh he he wants to weaken blacks King
side and go for some sort of a king side
attack with uh and knights brought to
the fifth rank maybe the queen comes
into the game so good things might
happen uh we have uh Ponte D5 black
replies to this in a very uh correct way
you have to counter your opponent's uh
side attack with a counter in the center
uh Ponte H5 Magnus just continues
pushing his H Pawn we have D captures on
e4 the characters and now Pawn to F6 you
don't have to play Pawn to F6 you could
also play something like H6 you could
play Pawn to B4 you could play a lot of
moves but F6 seems very solid and if he
can play it okay he he will play it but
now uh once the Knight lands on F5 there
will be a hole in Black's defenses with
Russia back to E3 and now even Pawn to
C4 and this is now
uh maybe giving Magnus uh too much a
captures on B5 a captors and not Knight
the H for now the Knight can come to the
F5 this Knight is already an H4 the
queen has access into the game the
Bishops are nicely placed okay your
light Square Bishop is uh blocked by
your E4 Pawn but uh still nicely placed
the position might might open up with
knights to C5 now and queen to G4 as
planned we have Knight 8 to B3 attacking
the rook and first Magnus trait with
Rook character 78 Rook character 78 and
now Knight G to F5 now you have to be
careful you don't want to do something
like a silly like Queen to F7 and then
you just blunder your queen Knight to H6
check will blunder the queen so here
after Knight G2 F5 with Bishop at the C8
now uh not allowing this Knight to move
and Rook to D1 uh here you could go for
the very aggressive H6 it's a it's a
very fun line and I will show it look at
the skin to h8 now you uh take on b31
Bishop captures Knight captures now age
captures and G7 the problem is black can
defend with Queen characters and G7 and
it's unclear how to continue this with
white obviously you don't want to trade
Queens uh and you're gonna move the
queen then black and let's say trade
captures captures or even better Knight
captures Queen to D7 and white will
always be better because blacks Black's
defenses are completely busted but still
uh Magnus feels that he can improve the
position before going for that final
push so he plays Rook to D1 uh Knight to
E6 now adding another uh the defender
into the game now the Knight can also
come to F4 if needed and now comes
Bishop capture some B3 C captures and
Magnus again improves the position a
little bit with King to H2 here there
was the fun uh line of knights the G6
and now if you capture Queen captures
you are you are threatening to just to
play H6 King to h8 now H6 and now it
seems like black is completely busted
but black has this very very tricky move
Knight to F4
attacking the White Queen and once you
play Queen to E8 there's this nasty
Bishop captures on F5 sacrificing The
Exchange on A8 and once white captures
an A8 you just bring back the bishop and
you lock the the White Queen out of the
attack like even if Bishop captures Pawn
captures you can play Queen to D5 okay
white is still uh pushing white has a
rook for two Bishops but still it's
still Bishops so if you can't um uh
Checkmate the black king uh black will
be okay so that's why Magnus doesn't go
for it instead he plays King to H2 and
now we have Rook to a to going after the
B Pawn uh if you if you can eliminate
that then the past B3 Pawn will be very
significant with Rook the D2 and now
Pawn to B4 and here Magnus just advances
his Pawn to C4 saying that okay if you
if you capture then your queen no longer
uh helps with the defense of the black
king uh but maybe it can be done and
here Queen captures and C4 was played
and it should be okay to play it uh but
Magnus finds uh such a deadly line that
and shows that Queen to C4 was actually
a terrible mistake he plays Knight the
H6 with check forcing black to go to h8
that's the only move the F7 is also
covered by the Knight and now Knight the
G6 with check we reached the position
from the thumbnail and there's only one
move you have to capture the Knight H
captures and now the whole point of it
Knight to F7 check King goes to G8 and
now Queen captures on G6 and now
uh the problem is if you go Knight to F4
which of course you can then look at
this Knight to H6 check came to h8
Bishop captures on F4 e captures and
Rook to d8 and there's no move uh you
can make here for example if Queen to C5
you guarded the bishop Knight F7 check
King goes to G8 and now H6 there's no
defense against Queen captures as the
bishop on f8 is pinned to The Rook so
instead after Queen to G6 uh Rook the A7
was played uh trying to to to defend any
way possible now uh this does mean you
have to give up The Rook but at least
you are getting your knight to F4 so
maybe you can survive this but here
Magnus just plays Bishop captures on A7
Knight to F4 and now Knight the H6 with
check this is the only way to continue
the attack King to h8 and now Magnus
plays king a queen to F7 he offers a
queen trade this is this was a bit uh
anti-climactic uh because there is a
beautiful win with Queen T8 I will just
show it because it's really awesome you
are just threatening to pick up the
bishop here and there's no no good way
to save it the queen cannot go to C5 to
help out with the defense you can't go
to F7 or G8 the Knight covers that so
it's uh it's game over okay you could
start some trouble here with Queen
captures on e4 but it's nothing you you
will capture an f8 with checking H7 F3
and the there's uh nothing black can do
here it's completely winning for white
uh but okay Magnus uh probably didn't
want to over calculate uh he played
Queen to F7 offer the queen trade and he
is sure that he will win this end game
we have Queen captures Knight captures
with check sort of going the
uh the the way capablanca would play I
think the G8 and now Knight the D6
attacks the bishop here uh with Bishop
to E6 and now Pawn to G3 Chase is away
the Knight Knight captures an H5 and now
Bishop the C5 preparing to start picking
up pawns but also just the trade uh
pieces and magnets is of the exchange so
he uh pretty much whatever he does is
completely winning with Knight to B7 uh
Bishop to H6 avoiding the trade attacks
The Rook we have Rook to d8 with check
King the F7 and now Bishop captures on
B4 here Bishop the C1 was played going
after the B2 pawn and while many lines
are winning for Magnus one is just uh
instant resign uh for for black so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh instant resigns move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook to D1 this is what Magnus played
and it was in this position on move uh
44 that Levy andreita luxon resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here you're either losing the bishop on
C1 or you're losing the bishop on E6
because once this bishop moves let's say
you capture Knight to d8 with check uh
forces the king away from the defense of
the best of the bishop covers the light
the dark Square so you have to go back
King the eight Knight captures now
you're just up a full Rook of course
completely winning so uh very nicely
played by by both of them uh Magnus
played this weird H4 move where he just
uh decided okay I'm gonna push in the
you know good things might happen and it
worked out very nicely for him uh so
yeah uh that's the game like I said hope
you enjoyed it uh one of the three last
games Magnus will play uh as as a world
classical Champion so we'll see what
happens in this game against the camera
and then tomorrow we have the game
against David Howell which will
officially be his last game as world
world classical Champion unless maybe
you know someone gets sick or something
but you know uh if nothing weird happens
then that should be it uh so yeah that's
the game hope you enjoyed that uh always
uh you know study the real Lopez It's a
Wonderful opening I would like to thank
Chris Foster Bernardo morani funky monk
Revolution reptiles YouTube and the
second car travel and tour safaris for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day